ja ich begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
des livestreams des seminars für das
wieder digitalität wir wollen heute mal
so ein bisschen
interaktiv werden und der sollte gleich
auch dass sie hier sein und es geht
heute um das thema was ist information
und auch was ist die infos fähre
das ist heute das zentrale thema um das
es dienst und
jetzt sind wir schon ein tor ist okay
[Musik]
das hat mich ja dass das geklappt
marcel luske wird hier dafür da sein
einfach auch ein bisschen zu helfen
1 billigen wie mal probleme gibt
hatte also an technischen dingen mit gut
ich habe es ja auch live und zwar wollen
jetzt wollen es machen die teilnehmer
hier im seminar und auch die tonmischung
vielleicht ausgestaltet werden dann tun
wir sind an wen genau dann müsste aber
sonst gibt es auch noch kopfhörer den
spendieren können
jetzt ist okay wunderbar ok und jetzt
möchte ich das machen
jetzt möchte ich sie mal bitten weil das
thema ja hier an was informationen
lautet dass sie mal ein paar minuten ein
bisschen mal für sich überlegen oder mit
ihrem besitzer neben sitzungen das
eigens information ist und dessen hier
gerne auch direkt rein stecken in dem
kommentar marcel ganz auch ein bisschen
moderieren du kannst auch hier im
kommentarbereich mal unterschreiben was
ist information überlegen sie sich mal
ein bisschen was macht was
morgen könnte informationen uns ja gar
kein begriff der wird ja ein bisschen
inflationär verwendet
wir wollen uns glauben sitzung gerade
diesem thema schreibt es also entweder
sind fans der einschreibung in die
fabrik oder sie notieren das für sich
dass wir ein bisschen zusammen
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit keine qualität hin
was die qualität die energie der stadt
gut und sie hier
[Musik]
die vitalität punkten vor schreibt die
adresse auch noch mal nicht hoffen
genau also die frage ist
ist information marcel hat hier schon
fleißig rein wirkt postet ich fange
einfach schon mal habe man hier gibt es
schon die gäste den ersten beitrag also
der marcel schreibt informationen kann
man als datenpakete ansehen und das
meist in datenpakete mit daten bedienen
eigentlichen dass wir unsere mit
ausnahmecharakter jahr also genügend
information
ja ich weiß nicht was jetzt zirkulieren
heute gehört sie aber damit schon mal
zusammen
kannst du beispiel geben für beide
pakete was sie da ist geld zu zahlen
oder ab oder weniger demokratisch ist
einfach buchstaben und wörter werden
scheint also ich habe informationen dass
es jetzt heißen sondern seinen
zeichnungen internet zahl zeichen sein
bereichen mehr anzeichen unsere sachen
im kreis die thematik findet man zahlen
wie dass der befehl unterzeichnen wenn
sie über ein jahr aber so wie es dann
packen und dann erlebt und sind genau
stringer jetzt zeichnen könnte und ihnen
die mittel ist daneben die gerade in
ganz libyen geflogen
diese parameter allerdings mal hier eine
zeitung
und so war es zum beispiel das war ich
immer ein sanftes informationen verstehe
ich einen raise optischen akustischen
optischen sensorischen reichs der über
nervenbahnen und der dekodiert wird über
nervenbahnen ins gehirn transportierten
doch wieder diskutiert genau das steht
jetzt auch hier genau momentan genau
also irgendwie haben sie jetzt eine gute
werke ein kommunikationssystem
entdeckung der werk als information muss
immer übersetzt werden das gibt es eine
übersetzungsleistung wieder als auch wie
man zum beispiel den text erst mal in
die schlüssel mussten sie fangen müssen
so muss jede form von information tik
17 das heißt es gibt einfache
übersetzungsleistungen bestimmte
strecken oder getränke zeichensysteme
informationen lässt sich auf
verschiedene weise in verschiedenen
sprachen oder zahlensystem nun
darstellen weil das der punkt gewesen
dass hier folgten denkt in verkehrter
richtung informationen bezogen auf den
menschen habe ich das jetzt verstanden
als wenigen menschen hinter massa ja und
dann würden sie sagen also informationen
zu erstellen wird so visuelle reiz
genommen
wir registrieren etwas nervt unser auge
wird gereizt das wäre smp riss tische
modell und dieser dieser eindruck der
wird eben über verschiedene kanäle dann
erarbeitet und ende am ausgegeben sodass
er zum beispiel auch am ende dass man
sich sprachlich beziehen kann
genau man kann auch registrieren
vielleicht durch bildgebende verfahren
länger und schauen was dann zu ihrem los
als gutes sei es gibt hier in unserem
übersetzungsprozess
ich glaub nicht eins zu eins und wir
mussten erst immer fragen wie er
studiert werden und die erträge gibt es
ein übersetzungs weg genau hier greift
oder ich würde unter karten zumal die
semantik aber wie wir informationen
gesprochen das muss man sich damit der
verkehr nicht mal den gästen zusammen zu
setzen
bei der wahl die meisten brauchen ok
lange einmal die höseler
das ist dann haben wir jegliche
wechselwirkungen zwischen der gegner
[Musik]
noch ungeschlagen
das ist alles was mir hilft gemeldete
bestehen
gut also es häufig fassen wir zusammen
sind ist ganz wichtig semantik was ist
es noch mal weiß dass jeder führen dass
semantik ist die sprache den worten ja
es hat mit der sprache auf jeden fall
ist oder vor steckt dahinter dem
arbeiten immer noch bedeutung bedeutung
des wortes ordnung
foto oder dieselmotor genau also es gibt
ja unterscheidung als diesmal das
eigentlich körpern auch sagen ziemlich
er nicht die logik die logen und
semantik diesen recht ähnlich als
disziplin
man ist einfach die bedeutung der gehalt
der bedeutungsgehalt auch die es sind
also nachfrage wäre es der sinn die
bedeutung ist akut und der gegenstand
auf den zahn zieht aber häufig wird
bedeutung sind synonym verwendet dass
man nicht gesagt habe damit seine
bedeutung oder nussbaum weiter punkte
erscheinen was man damit macht meint sie
auch so ein bisschen gesellschaften
wir kommen wir weiter punkten zu die
pragmatik das ist kein interessante
themenbereiche sprachwissenschaften also
was machen durch sprache auch durch mord
in ergebniseinbruch durch den fans mit
wörz als wir können mit wörtern eben
auch es ausrichten wenn es mir sagen ich
ernähre dich zum kaiser dann ist dieses
einer dieser sätze die ich hiermit ist
eine performative satz an der umsatz mit
dem licht
semantisch ausgedrückt wird zu etwas
neues geschaffen und realität wird dann
immer in einer status als pragmatiker
aus dem punkt dass mit der physik habe
ich noch nicht ganz fertig ganz
bestimmten können sie das nicht mehr so
einfach jegliche wechselwirkung und
sagte autor information und ich werde es
richtig nicht gegeben aber er gehört
schon oder forschungsschwerpunkten
sondern seine afrikanische jetzt kommt
der westen mit tänzen vielleicht auch
was die grenzen von informationen wenn
du sagst ist kann schnell alles nicht
geschwindigkeit der größte eingrenzen
die man sonst über genannt sie kennen
den betreffenden kommst ihren
angehörigen kochs genommen es ist eben
einen trichter
[Musik]
so sind doppelt richter und diese karte
hier
das kriegt es ist definiert durch die
wichtiges ziel und nur innerhalb dieser
wichtig kein ziel ist dass es keiner
bezahlen wie es war
beraten damit hier nach dem heutigen
stand der wissenschaft ist kann man
etwas schneller sein der sich
geschwindigkeit aber die grenzen der
übertragung sind natürlich nicht
geschlossen und das führt dazu dass es
wichtige punkt das eben in dem immer
mehr über das internet gemacht wird
immer mehr digitalisiert wird das ganze
thema ist dass der faktor raum und zeit
immer gewinner und ja nicht
geschwindigkeit ist ja sowas von schnell
das räumliche distanzen zumindest auf
der ebene der erde praktisch keine rolle
spielen wir können zur vortrags auf
einen anderen portugiesischen 2000 zu
erwarten so locker 100 sekunden das ist
der nec der mac und dann gibt's probleme
also jack heißt eben verzögerung und bei
computerspielen wichtiges thema auf das
kommende action und so weiter kann man
eine sitzung bei computerspielen kann
auch mit mit lichtgeschwindigkeit eine
lern schnelle übertragung durch systeme
und durch kings und so weiter so vor
keine verzögerung entstehen und gerade
in computerspielen können sehr kleine
verzögerung sehr viel bewirken wollen
gerade bei 3d spielen also shooter
counterstrike oder sonstigen spielen
könnt kleinste verzögerung zu großen
nachteilen führen weil man immer genau
zielen katzen wenn es um schießen die
betreffen also der lexus auch stimmen
die zweite glaube ich
information man das gut
sie sprechen jetzt hier wieder in der
kasse eines semantik betrifft oder den
og wir haben gesehen und die logik sind
sehr ähnlich von diskutieren
zum einen ist alles möglich immer
gekannt gestanden was versetzte wissen
sie dass bekannt diese sätze menschen
sich genauer als die analytischen sätze
werden gesetzt die in ihren rauen keine
genau gehen doch das antreten
das gegenbegriff zu analytisch
synthetisch immer als zu technisch
setzen
typische gesetze ein beispiel zu einem
mythischen satz können sie eingeben
der junge ist das genau
alle jungen gesehen sind unverheiratet
oder allerspätestens und weil das ist
eine schwierige frage es gibt zum
beispiel ein schwarzer schwan geld ist
also wir müssen uns länger zum beispiel
sagen alle dreibeinigen katze sind drei
war nicht das wäre nochmal ganz krasse
hat es wäre eine ganz klare tautologie
wo man ihn zweimal das selbst während
jetzt beim jungen gesehen ist da ist
schon ein bisschen mit informationen
enthalten
aber sie haben schon recht oder punkt
bei manchen zb man sprache erlernen
kinder
den muss man erst erklären lassen
junggeselle das bedeutet und weiter man
kann oder nicht irgendwann eine frau ist
ein junggeselle zb und auch dem kind im
alter von fünfzehn männliches kind was
man nicht paranoid ist das kann ja sein
15 wahrscheinlich oder mit 12 2 16
17-rückstand zu langsam 18 19 und danach
über 20 so langsam aber sie sehen dass
es da kommt dann schon eine semantische
dimension rein aber ganz klar
unterscheiden sind entschieden sind
davon zb synthetische sätze hätten sie
im beispiel jetzt
was ist ein synthetisches hat als eine
boeing keine technologie enthalten ist
was ist so etwas exotisches urteil mit
dem satz ganz nach kann schon genau
mache kann ich bin nach kant ist die
arithmetik 37 10 ein synthetischer seien
die meisten heutigen junge gewirkt sagen
dass analytisch schabernack kann dass
die chinesen sind
außerdem ist deswegen weil er sich das
so vorstellt dass wir in der arithmetik
in einem logischen raum bzw der medien
biologischen zeit verschiedene
positionen aneinander reiben in dem das
in der leinwand chance von derzeit
biologisch ist vonstatten gehen und
leben wurden konkret ist als inhalte
gehalt und aktive dieses position tätig
genauso wie die haben die geometrie ist
verkannt aus ethischen die
linienbestimmung dreieck konstruktion
des dreiecks das für den präsidenten und
die meisten mathematiker nun sei es das
anekdotische das wird dem produzieren
aber mein anderes beispiel umstritten
sind die nicht egal ist auf abrüstung
als vorne erfahren
genau genommen oder eben auch die sonne
geht es morgens auf das muss nicht
notwendiger so sagt sie sei aber im
begriff oder münchen in der liga fast
fertig ist bei sie sehen schon wäre
mitten auf der wiese liegen würde
das sind alles sehr unscharf werden auch
die sonne sondern genau das ist auch
sehr umsichtig bilder oder zum beispiel
wir sitzen genau die hier im raum wir
sie als personen in den begriffen einer
person ist nicht enthalten
dass sie hier heute sitzen das ist nicht
notwendig oder zb mal handys blau zu
meistern
klaus heute das ist nicht im begriff von
mir gelegen dass klaus die meisten
urteilen die wir tätigen synthetischen
und das bringt eben uns wieder zu der
frage das stagnation ist wir haben es
immer mit sehr viel information
jetzt haben wir weitere melden gleich
dahinter
waren mal abbildung 1 gut hat sie würden
sagen war abgesagt
ja also das ist natürlich ein bisschen
sprachphilosophie schwer also tatsache
sagten händler
der unterschied zwischen zwischen
tatsache und sachverhalt weiß dass
jemand schon was der ist ja so kann man
es sagen man kann auch sagen die
sachlage durch mehrere tatsachen
ausgedrückt es ist ein bisschen
rundschau
man könnte auch sagen die tatsache
tatsache dass die bei auftritten könnte
auch sagen sachverhalt wäre eine
mögliche welt wie es sein könnte wie er
sich verhalten könnte aber nicht
unbedingt muss also mögliche welt aber
ich finde hinweis gut auf tatsachen
sachverhalt sind nämlich letztendlich
kompositionen und libero position habe
ich jemanden sagen ich habe es nie
gegessen
opposition und sorgen was ist eine
position dass jetzt wieder ein bisschen
an zu schreiben eine zuweisung genau die
position eigentlich nur eine vorlage als
datei vorstellen dann seine behauptung
kann nicht eine position ist eine these
ist sagen die kritisch wäre der begriff
wenn es dann heißt obwohl heißt
vorliegen und wie schwer das sind es ist
es wetten in juristischem anschlusses
meldungen proposition information eines
das satzes also der ganze verein dafür
ist dass wir diese form in das alte
fühlen könnte ist eine promotion findet
dass ich fühle dass ich denke das wissen
alles provokation dazu und bin ich denke
dass hier gerade zeigen sich das sitzt
das ist ein problem heraus die aufgrund
einer wartung zu klampen genau wissen
aussage auch die bar oder falsch sein
kann das ist auch an den zu beginn also
ist es war heinz wert
hier sitzen so ein teilnehmer
er sagt dass position und diese position
kennt waren falsch sie ist
wahrscheinlich falsch ist jetzt
natürlich 200 ist also liebe youtube
zuschauern zu sehen
sie verpasst ein ganz ganz nah ich sehe
jetzt hier dummerweise ich den counter
angezeigt dass ein bisschen ärgerlich
achhammer doch oben nicht ins feld tritt
aber egal
ok sonst war
beide stars eigentlich den namen der
wege das ist damals und information
gerade wenn zum beispiel lustig
förderbedingungen aber auch aufpassen
und die veranstaltung ist das
entscheiden welche informationen für
sich gewinnen kann
als elektronisches sage lieber auf die
technischen informationen und an seinem
comeback
das kontrollieren wieder dass hier das
schaden könnte was daraus eben genau
also das ist ein bisschen problematisch
physikalisch werfen den punkt man
natürlich es gibt so was wie sind es
daten oder sagt man der sinnes daten
reizungen die sich der hier als
informationen bilden lassen
aber die frage ist halt physikalische
objekte oder zuständig ob die
proposition aale semantisch bedeutet
dann ist dem antichrist als auch eine
reizung eines nerven als etwas
bedeutsames an der bedeutung träger der
bedeutung zustand gefasst worden
das ist ein bisschen schwierig bei
physikalischen salon entspricht heute
gegen auf eine musikalische
informationen weitere meldung die ich
nicht gerade gesehen haben
von entscheidungen treffen
ach ja okay also bin eben jeder
opposition
[Musik]
praktisch null und eins momentan zu
machen gibt auch keinen kranken computer
mit überladung zu stemmen hat einfach
keine informationen
gute frage
also das kontinuum als ist farbe
praktisch nur dann informationen wenn
sie digital dargestellt oder erst im
alter sich als solche wie sie jetzt
kunst und das auge trägt schon eine
information ist für mich so gilt es an
halo und wahnsinn will also die frage
ist gibt es natürlich physikalischen
daten und informationen wird das ist die
frage
und sie haben es ja auch für ihren vater
als optischer weigern auf optischer reiz
der dann auch verarbeitet wird man den
gedanken die wehr mit sie würden auch
sagen die information nicht schon
physikalischen vom 1 darum liegt ja ich
wollte nur noch sein
die welt
sie es nicht und die farbe ist eine
information stammt bieten es nicht
angehen haben das ist eine gute die
anzahl leute sagen die zahlen nichts
mehr als mit meinem zahlen ja dahin ist
und vielleicht sogar ist vielleicht die
philosophie des geistes in diesen fragen
die interessen der debatte wenn ich
diese sache ob ich überhaupt wissen dass
er glücklich gewesen das sind neben dass
sich nicht selber gemacht habe gemacht
also sollten das genau wegen dieser tage
eigentlich alle informationen sammle
beratung im kern ist als der mensch
natur das board war es dennoch eine
reihe hinter kim zum ersten mal haben
sie eben übernommen
genau das ist noch ein zusätzlicher
punkt sehr sollt wirbt informations
erkenntnis zum erkenntnisgewinn oder
direkt das daraufhin für den vorzug des
ab genau als erfolg feiert der
vollständig erhalten ist haben wir hier
vorstellen diesen gehalten also das
folgendes weiß ich alles auch
informationen über rot wenn ich zum
beispiel physikalisch der stimme als die
wellenlänge
oder muss ich nicht rot gesehen habe im
sinne des eindrucks also dass quale dass
b es ist wo sie sein wie es ist ein ton
zu hören oder wenn ich von der herz zahl
die ich wissen kann
um wirklich diese diesen begriff und
dieses phänomen als solches voll zu
verstehen können was meinen sie
also dass da immer noch dieses diese
qualitäten die mit empfunden
sogar von zeitungen aber das was
eigentlich der welt dass ich mir alles
vorstellen zum beispiel gibt es ein
wiedersehen
viertes buch ist wie funktioniert aber
ich so etwas nicht zu wenig
gut also ich glaube das ist ein
wichtiger punkt zum thema physikalische
informationen gerade potenzielles daten
spielt der punkt von nicole wissing
konkurrieren um auch die frage nach der
quali also wie es ist ein rotwein tast
alter zu haben
unabhängig von dem was ende hier in
unserem gehirn ankommen
das kann die firma gar nicht beschreiben
dass die hat man nichts geschrieben man
kann einen blinden nicht semantisch das
nur durch zeichen zu erkennen geben der
wie es ist zu sehen
er wird dadurch nicht sehen oder nicht
ein bild vor augen haben nur wenn sie
beschreiben den sinn dass button
beispiel vom abfüller ich kann ihnen
sagen beschreiben wie der schmeckt aber
wenn sie sich reingebissen haben wir
sind die trotzdem genau so ist es genau
auch geschmackssache
das mag vielleicht fälle geben wo man
von einem bekannten service datum
schließen kann
logisch auf ein unbekanntes zum beispiel
wenn man zwei rote meer hat dass die
welt vor augen vorstellen wie es wäre
wenn dieser ein bisschen heller
bewegungen dass man begeistert sondern
eindruck hat aber das ist eine
psychologische frage und diese ganzen
fragen jetzt sind es eindrücken die
betreffen die touristische
erkenntnistheorie wie zum beispiel von
demis jung oder george buckley oder john
bock das sind diese britischen im
juristen die haben
18 jahrhundert gewirkt und für die
hantel hat es alles ein großes spiel
vielen dank für die habe ich noch eine
meldung dass sehen vielen dank für die
depressionen
marcel hat hier schön aber bis
zusammengefasst das wird auch eine gute
idee wenn die subventionen so den
standard diskussion einfach in eines
saales als information nicht hier
einfach rein
dass man da so ein bisschen mithalten ok
heute geht zu lesen wer von ihm kennt
den namen persönlich in den schatten
genau hatte der iss geben
weiter dieses oxford internet institute
und der ist so eine der prominentesten
denker der gegenwart die man sich mit
dem thema der digitalisierung und
vielleicht auch der digitalität der
verwende den begriff digitalität fast
her verwendet andere griff er sagt es
geht um die 14 revolution oder es eben
die infos gehen
das ist
das ist ein thema und ich habe ihn ein
paar texte um geschickt haben sie alle
bekommen wir noch nicht von mir
regelmäßig möchte ich nehme bekommt kann
mich einfach mal anschreiben dann nehme
ich an dass sie in offenen verteilung
ist etwas mitgenommen nicht dann halt
nochmal schreiben und sie finden auch
die folien jetzt der heutige sitzung
direkt neben youtube direktor und
präsenter die können sich unter druck ok
also ihm geht es vor allem um die infos
faire und wir haben jetzt hier ein paar
fragen und bestehende flori die vierte
revolution wurde besteht philosophie die
information
ihn interessiert was ist eine info
sphären als infos fähre wird das sein
was ich an antritt digitalität im
bereich der digitalität worum besteht
die metaphysik der infos werden
das sind so die vier fragen die hier
besonders im zentrum stellen zugleich
als es geht jetzt endlich darum was
verändern diese die situation und der
wir uns momentan befinden informationen
wasser auch alles jetzt informationen
gemeinden ist aber wohl ebenfalls
informationen eine sehr sehr wichtige
stellen wird einem und wo wird und so
was die informationsflut zu einer
metapher sprechen und wir also schier
unendlich veneman informationen
überhaupt speicher verfügt die über die
informationen die uns durch die ersten
anthologie qualitativ und natürlich kann
ja die weit hinaus
ich habe ja so jeweils konzentrieren
desinfektion was die natur ist er
senator ist alles das was die
physikalischen grenzen betreffen also
die farben die können physikalische
realisiert und auch biologe schließen
das ist die erste motto die zweite natur
ist die kultur und sie wissen auch in
der kultur darf ihn ist wirklich erst
mal richtig an dass informationen eine
gewisse für uns darstellen
denken sie an bücher druck guttenberg
wir haben das in der letzten sitzung die
gutenberg galaxis als mit dem bücher
druck gegangen
wirklich exponentiell informationen zu
verbreitern zu verbreiten
und jetzt haben wir eben nicht mehr
diese gutenberg galaxis und jetzt haben
wir die infos fähre von der nokian v wie
die spricht und andere nehmen dass die
vitalität und hier gibt es einen ganzen
neue nun von informationen durch das
internet durch präsentiert
digitalisierung durch vernetzung und so
weiter so fort und wir wollen uns jetzt
fragen was geht mit dieser neuen kultur
der neuen form von inflation einher
und zwar nicht zuletzt auch mit
also metaphysisch und mehr können und
die zusätzliche frage hier stehen
nämlich auch genetisch des interesses
scheint auch sie als teilnehmerin und
thailand besonders zu interessieren was
ihr recht verstanden habe also ich die
dessen implikationen geht mit der info
sphäre einher mit der physischen und
logischen sehr nette weise ja das wird
deutlich so gebraucht ok jetzt beginnt
er hier erste european group asx in
science and technology nist salvatori
und information seite her fordert
informationen revolution heißt die
change verfahren ihre größe blenden von
medical systems 15 de ist der präsident
des communication management education
of information communication and
computational resources weiter beschluss
als solche geht es darum dass wir eine
ethische organisation darauf hinweist
dass seit den 50er jahren seit der zeit
wo es eben diese darf arbeiten dass
systeme in großer menge gibt dass da
eben da
sonst werbung nation gehört was auch
immer gehört ist deshalb der welt ist
philosophischer hoch problematisch ist
die welt ist die welt alles was
existiert gibt es die welt überhaupt
immer unbekanntes handwerk gibt es nicht
muslime gibt gibt es die welt nicht
bellt ist nur eine idee also hier nicht
richtig scharf jetzt begrifflichen
argumentiert als die welt wird seit den
50ern tief greifen und unumkehrbar und
auf eine problematische weise
revolutioniert das ist das was für die
vierte revolution
er hat ein paar andere revolutionen die
wir auch noch mehr haben uns nach dem
anschauen und das eben damit jetzt große
probleme entstehen so und das ist der
aufhänger und jetzt sagte zu seinem buch
die 14 revolution sagt der freund ist
dieses buch handelt von einem
auswirkungen die uns die digitale
informations und
kommunikationstechnologien uns rennt
darauf haben wie wir uns selbst
verstehen wie wir mit einer weiter
miteinander in beziehung treten und wie
wir unsere welt gestalten und mit ihr
interagieren nanotechnologie das
internet der dinge werde 2.0
semantisches web cloud computer
computerspiele mit bewegungserfassung
smartphone-apps tablet computer mit
touchscreens kibi des augmented reality
kürzt der begleitung um dem plante droht
fahrerlose autos wäre das 3 d drucker
identitätsdiebstahl onlinekurse soziale
medien cyberkrieg techno viele punkt
techno foam stellen sich dieselbe frage
was kommt als nächstes
also das sind die aktuellen themen
das sind die punkte die wir als
untersuchung für sucht neben ernst
nehmen müssen wir uns gedanken die der
philosoph fragt sich wofür sind wir
natürlich auch was steckt dahinter gibt
es eine verbindende perspektive aus der
sich all diese phänomene als aspekt
eines einzigen makroskopischen trends
interpretieren das schwer zu beantworten
ist die frage auch deshalb weil wir nach
wie vor gewohnt sind in den etat des
werkzeuges internet aktion in der welt
wo mit uns selbst zu sehen
in wahrheit sind aus in den umwelt
gestaltende anthropologische sozial und
interpret aktive kräfte geben
sie schaffen prägen unsere geistige
materielle wirklich verändern unser
selbstverständnis modifizieren die wir
miteinander in beziehung treten und uns
auf uns selbst beziehen sie bringen
unsere welt bedeutung in einem neuen
besseren stand und alter zu tun sie
ebenso tief greifend bieten fassen
konnte
es ist also einfach nur seine faktische
aufnahme der momentanen situation wir
sind diagnose
hier tut sie und ich glaube den würde
auch jeder zustimmen oder gibt es wenn
ihnen jemand der diese these nicht
zustimmt wird dass wir es hier mit einem
möglichen revolution
natürlich kann man jetzt fragen hängt
davon ab was der blutung ist
also gelogen wenn ich sie recht
verstiess sagen so positiv ist das alles
nicht anders darstellen will
genau aber dass man sagen auf jeden fall
revolutionieren also im um starken szene
würden sie auch sagt also ihr film eine
starke nutzung statt
die frage ist wie sie zu bewerten ist
unsere revolution zu funktionieren weil
ich glaube dass eigentlich ist ja auch
ein betrachten möchte irgendwie ähnlich
den prozessen voraussetzen dass ich sage
nur sprache
dahinter steckt das ist eigentlich nur
aus um seinen bedarf mit allen
funktionen und landesregierung zum
veränderungsprozess fesseln und zu
überlegen sind die überlassung
installationen zeigen und den feldhasen
einkünfte aber nicht dass nicht alles
weiß in welchem maße sich dass wir
nichts wiedergutzumachen
ok genau das ist die entscheidende frage
revolution bedeutet hier kommt was
qualitativ neues hier gibt es einen
paradigmenwechsel
das ist der zentrale begriff schreibt
auch sein
ich musste also den providern
die menschen ja sowas mündlicher kultur
mündliche kommunikationskultur zu
schriftlicher kommunikationskultur so
was meint und damit gehen ganz neue
entwicklung einher
ganz gleich was hält und wollte auch
hier einbringen will ich das letzte mal
muss hat man diese gut lesen kann ich
auch anders nutzen
das sehen kann mit dieser revolution
geht auch immer exponentielles wachstum
an hier also revolutionen sind da
durchaus sein dass sie beschleunigte und
so wirklich als studierende entwicklung
darstellt das ist ein jahreswachstum
also a x x-factor
vor 6405 geht es ja der wert wenn ihr
die zeit
und hier ist mich hier ist der jetzt 78
oder das ist egal
als er und ein exponentielles wachstum
sieht ergebnisses beginn ist sehr sehr
flach und schließen warum das ist der
punkt kommissionen werden dadurch
ausgezeichnet sagt man dass sie mich ein
jahreswachstum haben also dieses
konstante und das hier eben
exponentielle hier oben faktor ist und
dessen
anfangs bereich noch nicht genau sehen
kann ob es sich wirklich um
exponentielles wachstum handelsregister
bestimmten punkt der ist finanzielles
wachstum unter den jahren wächst das
können sie auch mal zum abschluss der
funktionär aus mattighofen genaue
chronik zu kommen
es kann auch die funktion cynamite.de
oder so aber zweimal gefährlich
exponentiellen die quadratische haben
der ex quadrat auch dann ist es so dass
es einst unter dem wert bleibt ungefähr
das heißt gar nicht erkennen kann und
das ist ein faktor der auch revolution
manchmal mehr ist hier also fühlt ich
könnte sich langsam daran zugehen und
sich ernsthaft zum beispiel bis mir bei
dem revolutionsgericht als minister klar
dass sich das ändern wird darf
vielleicht schon geändert wenn wir uns
aktiv sind einige aber nicht was sich da
was sich geändert hat zum beispiel frage
ich mich nämlich das neue wäre ja dass
man informationen hätte von denen man
darf man ableitet sein also die
erkenntnis abweichung springs wie ist
die welt auf die mauer zum beispiel mein
name ist etwaige wirbelte material in
eine ganz neue angehen reise mit dem
degen
es gibt kaum zu geben da fragen sie mich
auch wieder ein album ist wenn man denn
davor umgegangen
also gab es etwa zwischen formationen
das innenleben der mühle ist oder wie
gehen wir damit um mit dem was in den
gegenständen ist aber sich von
informationen unterscheiden
also ist dass die partie erst mit
informationen über jeden schritt und ich
glaube wenn wir wissen schreiben können
wie es davor war dass wir dann auf eine
erkenntnis darüber haben
wie oft wir eine koalition unter punkt
der glaube ich auch die pistol ogi am
gelenk unser verhältnis zu den dingen
jedes ding enthält prinzip irrt
unendlich viele informationen und ob es
relevant ist diese information hängt von
unserem interesse
ich kann zum beispiel mich für etwas
interessieren was die beschaffenheit des
stiftes zb die anzahl seiner atome 10 25
oder sogar ungefähr denn das kann mich
interessieren und dann werden die
generische zeit relevant ich kann mich
aber auch dafür interessieren sich aus
einer physikalischen sich sondern zb aus
der chemischen sicht ich kann mich dafür
interessieren welche schadstoffe enthält
die täter wieder drin ist und da wird
plötzlich mehr antreten qualitäten die
sie in dem stück oder das design und das
verbraucht informationen ist auch immer
betrifft die perspektive die wir auf
einen gegenstand werden
beim prinzipiell dieser stift und
physikalisches objekt unendlich viele
informationen
wenn ich nur die perspektive genug
andere kann ich immer wieder neuen
informationspunkte decken und jetzt mal
ein punkt aber ich frage mich aber auch
information gefehlt und ja
also ich glaube hat also ich glaube man
kann information recht weit verstehen
sind würde ich auf vorschlag
informationsbericht einzustehen und
verstehen und zwar hier auch auf der
romantik ist ein bisschen anders
also geht es hier darum dass wir etwas
verstehen können oder auch das
synthetische können wir etwas neues
heraus
das scheint mir ganz wichtig entsteht ja
so eine art aha-effekt und auch eine
gewisse pragmatik können wir damit was
anfangen
das wären wichtige punkte in der noch
viel zu nehmen müssen nämlich
[Musik]
das ist ein wichtiger punkt jetzt hatten
sich in schenefeld ihren klaren dass man
sechsmal höheres wachstum
hier musste aber in hessen genau richtig
richtig vertragen genau das richtige
also neben als nochmal quadratischen
oder wie auch immer man muss aber doch
konkretes mama ist das ist ihr das nicht
real zu hier hier wissen angelegt das
würden sie verstört hier einmal jammer
entworfen oder auch mal ein buch bietet
ihre mixa habe es kommen einfach mit den
exponenten vielen dank für die
wissenschaftler ist würden sie denn für
die y achse ja relativ gut dass uns
dieser punkt genommen da würde ich zb
hier fragen würde ich an zu schreiben
ökonomische wert man könnte zum beispiel
geld oder man könnte zum beispiel
zuschauerzahl einfach ökonomisch
relevante wert
geld oder verbreitung oder sowas
aber geld scheint mir wichtig diesen als
ein neuer markt wenn wir mehr biss
bekommen dann mehr gewähren anfangen
nicht dass wir damit mal ganz große
kunden
das nennt man fange aber sehr schnell
merken wir dass es an verbreitet und das
wäre ein riesen markt geschaffen und das
ist zum phänomen kommt die sich
gegenseitig pushen an dass das thema
direkt stimmt und synergieeffekte dollar
kaufen
das ist ein wachstum zu tun als es
ökonomische faktoren im kern von monika
aber das sind so grundsätzliche
prinzipien die eigentlich revolutionen
beschreiben dass es hier
[Musik]
vernetzungen gibt die sich gegenseitig
hoch drückt immer einfach neues
paradigma schwester zwar noch eine
meldung habe ich ja okay dann geben wir
weiter
und jetzt sagt lori die folgendes gesagt
in diesem buch skizziert lediglich ein
paar ideen seine für
informationen und formen einer
philosophie der geschichte für eine
philosophie der natur in form einer
philosophie infos fähre für eine
philosophische anthropologie in form
einer firmen revolution unserem
selbstverständnis und jetzt kommt die
vierte nach der kopernikanischen der
darwinistischen und erfreut die vierte
revolution erste war die vom kopernikus
also die egozentrische swiss
heliozentrische weltbild als komiker hat
insofern beruhigt dass er gesagt hat
nicht mehr dreht sich die sonne und die
erde ist und die erde hin zum
heliozentrischen weltbild die zweite war
die darwinistische darin schreibt die
band im 19 jahrhundert das eben der
mensch sein kontinuierlich zum tierreich
steht und dass eben bestimmte prozesse
die selektion mutation dazu führen dass
fortschritt zustande kommen dass der
menschheit nichts besonderes ist sondern
dass die menschen deswegen vielleicht
eine ausnahmestellung ab weil die
zwischen klima und die zu den nächsten
tierischen verwandten existieren weil
die einfach ausgerottet wurden von homo
sapiens hat er hat also seinen engsten
verwandten einfach wahrscheinlich
ausgeweitet und ist in ganz gestorben
die an der tat
deswegen ist eine kluft aber eigentlich
gibt es ein kontinuum und dann die
dritte sagt er die frösche sind freut
dass also wir gar nicht herr im eigenen
haus sind sondern das unterbewusste und
sonstige dinge auf sexualität dass das
unterdrückte dass das sehr viel größere
bedeutung hat als wir glauben dass wir
nicht glauben sollten immer alles
präsent zu haben sind das da sondern zu
schleier gibt das unbewusste und dass er
mir direkt eine beziehung jetzt sagt es
gibt die viertel das ist eben die der
infos fährt seine philosophie der
politik in form der entwicklung von
multi akteurs systemen die sich der
aufgabe globale probleme zu bewältigen
gewachst sagen können wir haben also das
ist dann die grundannahme und jetzt
kommen doch was interessantes und das
betrifft jetzt die frage wie wir mit
logisch über diese firma eingetreten
zeigt natürlich freundes schließlich
werden sie bei der lektüre dieses fest
das ist eine menge nur vorläufige und
versuchsweise verwendete begriffe und
termini enthält zusammen mit neologismen
anonymen und fachausdrücken dergleichen
versuche zur umgestaltung unserer
sprache ärgerlich seien
sie lassen sich jedoch nicht immer
vermeiden meinen ringen um eine balance
zwischen die lesbarkeit und genauigkeit
offensichtlich und ich habe mich
entschlossen erst nichts zu verbergen
genau wie ein guter schwimmer einer
anschaulichen analogie des pozo
friedrich weiß man's zufolge der
seinerzeit im grünen kreis zu angehört
stromaufwärts zu schwimmen sollte ein
guter versuch die schwierige kunst
versprach aufwärts bedenken gegen den
strom sprachlicher gewohnheit ich teile
diese ansicht unbedingt wenn man jedoch
auch darüber im klaren dass meine
bemühungen um eine erfassungs umfassend
und tiefgreifend 9 dms geistiger
hinsicht zu tun haben und zu halten
bleiben
was ist jetzt damit gesagt das schalten
ganz dem fall wird es sein
also es geht hier darum dass wir wenn
wir es gelangen neue nutzung zu tun
haben und damit geht immer exponentiell
oder hiernach in den kreistag ein
strenges wachstumskurses quantitativ das
ist
in der komischen meister ist geht auch
immer chronologisch dinge mit einem
ökologisch meinen es gibt neue realität
die wir neu beschreiben müssen für die
wir noch keine begriffe oder wird zum
beispiel die sie gerne diese ganzen
buchdruck hat erstmal eine ganze neue
reihe von technologien überhaupt möglich
gemacht die damit zusammenhängen
er hat neue berufe geschaffen und
soziale ständig aber auch neue phänomene
wie eben zb seinem buch seite auch neue
bücher die auf eine ganz neue weise
gedruckt werden kann
das heißt wir bekommen es wenn wir es
mit einer revolution zu tun haben immer
mit neuen phänomenen für die wir noch
keine begriffe haben adäquaten versuchen
immer mit den begriffen verletzt wurde
der vorherige revolution das neue zu
fassen und werde feststellen dass die
begriffe nicht unsere wörter werden
immer müssen es bezeichnet müssen es
auch definieren und deswegen findet es
also sehr lohnenswertes unterfangen von
familie hier neue begriffe zu prägen die
diese neue realität ist sie denn gibt
adäquat fassen er hat jetzt ein paar
vorschläge
er sagt infos fähre er sagt die info box
gekommen drauf und das online also das
leben
das sind so ein paar versuche ich habe
auch ein paar angebote
vielleicht kommen dort auf gesprächen
die ich auch gerne hier im laufe des
seminars entwickeln unser versuch
stellen wird das als ganz wichtige
müssen wir schauen neue begriffe zu
prägen das sofern wir sagen dass es sich
um den täter handeln die mit dieser
neuen revolution
sofern es sie denn gibt ein händler das
ist alles konnte sie immer nur bände das
voraussetzen dass es einen realismus
genau also jetzt gibt es folgendes jetzt
bringt hier flori die die unterscheiden
zwischen verschiedenen technologien
verschiedene album machine und platz
vorstellen er sei als folgendes befinden
sich die technologien
zwischenmenschlichen anwender natürlich
auslöser können wir sie näher bestimmen
als technologien erster ordnung als zb
ist ein flug ist eine technologie erste
ordnung und er bringt hier eine grafik
als eine technik die erste ordnung jetzt
eine vermittlung zwischen den menschen
als an tür und
ein flug zb mit dem der schiebt sich
eben zwischen mich und den acker dann
muss ich eben selbst nicht mehr sagen
von herrn wobei dann wäre die hand
sozusagen also fragen jetzt die kriegen
wir den menschen eigentlich so hin dass
wirklich andere seite stehen ohne selbst
technologische implikation zu haben ich
möchte das beschneiden denken sie mal
dann wenn sie keinen flughafen dann
müssen sie halt von hand machen oder sie
nehmen halt anders instrumente dann wird
es also instrumente hier eigentlich
selbst aber der mensch hat hat auch eine
hand ja und ich frage mich halt können
wir wirklich technologie von mensch zu
trennen oder ist der mensch nicht selbst
auch schon technologisch technologisch
gestaltet ausgestattet ausgelöst wir
haben doch auch dem kunden technologien
waren
wir haben eine hand und zwar der oper
mir waren daumen dass er das was uns von
affen unterscheidet können ja nicht den
daumen reformieren gegenüber setzen
zahlungen anzuführen
das ist sehr praktisch eine
technologische revolution revolution
gewesen die auch er ist vieles möglich
gelegt also das muss so ein bisschen
problematisch betrachten ich glaube dass
der mensch selbst auch in sich schon
durch seine biologie mit dieser technik
iat
[Musik]
ja
klar natürlich aber da geht es dann
verschiedene stufen abwehr hat natürlich
auch in sich mitteln etwas zu öffnen
oder super also ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher ob man das so streng sehen sollte
dann kann man ja sagen in technologien
ultra ordnung sind eben die von natur
aus uns gegebenen möglichkeit unsere
hände unsere füße und vor allem uns will
greift werk zurück sagte auch kein ja
sofern sie eben wirklich das instrument
einsetzt kann ich glaube das werde in
dem es muss als mittel zum zweck die
musst etwas machen als um etwas zu
verfolgen ist also internationalität
müsste im spiel ist ausgerichtet auf der
press nun auch finalität als ein klares
ziel vor augen und das würde ich bei
mikroorganismen nicht ansetzen aber zb
vielleicht bei dicken fischen also diese
angreifer mit saugnäpfen dass die eben
dazu dass zu öffnen das ist in diesem
sinne würde das auch den hessischen und
grad an so dass sie sterben oder so
was auch klappt unter umständen oder
natürlich kämpfen mit
an meinem krebs ist ja ganz klar diese
zange die dazu da wo es etwas zu öffnen
das ist praktisch zum werkzeug was ihr
team zur natur begonnen hat das möchte
ich so ein bisschen in frage stellen
da passt dass er das als ausgangspunkt
nicht würde vorstand technologie multer
auch in meinem wesen oder meteoriten
menschen tragen bzw eigentlich geld da
ist es die menschen als naturwesen ist
schon irgendwie technologisch oder wie
sehen sie das
dann würde ich sagen dass die anwendung
der technologie auf die natur kategorien
fehler ist hineininterpretieren
wenn es vielleicht auch was uns da aber
die technologie irgendwo da was wenn ich
das erste werk von außen bequemeres mir
nicht anhören
wichtig war es zumindest nämlich
natürlich also wenn er berichtet die
presse
ja genau sie würden sagen technologie
erst aufnehmen mit der 200 richtig ist
wir würden noch einen schritt fehlen
dazwischen zwischen menschen die ihnen
vorher möchte ich die technik entwickeln
konnten uns einen denkleistung
verbringen
also da kann ich einfach ein auto bommel
ich denken kann und man kann nicht eine
axt nutzen wenn er keinen denkleistung
gebe müsse man aber keine anderen
probleme haben oder mich anhängen
ja das würde damit bestimmt einhergehen
das wäre implikationen auf jeden fall
aber für die ich denke mal für die bloße
terminologie also ordnung würde es jetzt
glaube ich kein einwand sagen sie würden
einfach sagen gefehlt noch dazu dass da
eben noch gewisse entwicklung
vorausgegangen sein müssen die adäquaten
sie gleichen menschen ausmachen
das ist dieselbe diskussion wie wenn man
von hinten gegen stellt nicht die von
menschen schaffen
ob die dann natürlich wird es
problematisch ist wenn wir uns darauf
einigen dass alle menschen eigen ist
schon immer dann kann man mich auch
nicht billig zu haben ja also es geht
oder
man könnte sagen alle ordnungen weil sie
ein vom menschen geschaffen sind oder
aus der menschen hervorgingen wäre in
ordnung erst noch in deutschland wurden
weil sie ihm aus den menschlichen geist
entsprungen
aber jetzt kommt eben noch eine weitere
gliederung theorie die ich interessant
finde aber jetzt sagte technologie
zweiter und sind jene die anwender nicht
mehr mit der natur
justina tour mit anderen technologien
verknüpfen das heißt es sind
technologien deren auslöser an andere
technologie sind so sieht es jetzt hier
bei ihnen aus haben sie eine idee dass
das was man ein beispiel nehmen könnte
für technik
das wird sogar fast schon richtung
trittin dabei verlor idee was klingt
etwas gibt es für technologien deren
auslöser anderen technologien sind wir
hier
schrauben habt ihr auch schon wird
ist es bei schlecker chloriden genau der
ist also bei frauen sehr im schraube
neben der sammlung gehören haben sie
noch eine andere idee
sie haben sich gemeldet
das ist dabei jedem wenn zb neuronale
netze aber ist
[Musik]
ja ja würde ich auch vermuten dass es zu
tritten ordnung gehört ja sagen
zb welcher schritte im mittelmeer erst
technologie und so leicht etwas zu geben
dass es
sie beschlossen welche diesen geräten
rausgeflogen warte ist ist die frage ob
ich kann unsere besucher sagen könnte
auch in diese richtung ist das
technologische prozesse
der test stellt sich auch die frage ob
ein system gestürzt
[Musik]
ja dass diese frage mit uns auf jeden
fall stellen und mir scheint hier die
technologie zweiter ordnung ist eine
technologie die unsere zweite natur
betrifft also unsere kultur das ist da
gibt es eben auch steigerungsform werden
verhältnisse von technologie zur
technologie er bringt jetzt hier ein
beispiel der motor verstanden als jede
technologie die anderen technologien mit
energie versorgt ist wohl die wichtigste
technologie zweiter ordnung wieder
tausende lang haben wassermühlen und
windmühlen energien nützliche bewegung
umgewandelt
doch erst aus der dampfmaschine den
verbrennungsmotor und elektromotor als
aus dem tragbare energieversorger werden
die sich zwischen nutzern und andere
technologien platzieren lassen
noch immer wenn darauf besteht wenn die
industrielle revolution vor ort auf und
verbreitet sich über den globus also der
motor kann zum beispiel zwischen insel
eingelegt werden
da gibt es das mühlrad einem mühlstein
den kann ich am treiben mit einem motor
oder die schiffsschraube kaiser für
verschiedene übertragungen von energie
ansetzen und damit verschiedene zwecke
reicht ich kann technologien kombinieren
ich kann eine schiffsschraube kommt
indirekt in der sehr flexibel in
schichten der technologien und jetzt
kommt er mit die dritter ordnung die
technologien dritter ordnung
einschließlich des internets der dinge
sind im chor bei uns die schwerfälligen
menschlichen zwischen wesen aus der
schleife zu entfernen
in einer defragmentieren und
vollintegrierten infos wäre wird die
unsichtbare koordination der geräte
untereinander so reibungslos
funktionieren wie das zusammenspiel
zwischen ihrem smartphone im laptop und
zwischen diesen drucker das ist schwer
vorherzusagen was passieren wird wenn
die dinge sich untereinander austauschen
werden doch ich wäre nicht überrascht
wenn computer und softwareunternehmen in
der nahezu geräte anwendungsentwicklung
für 3
ihr fernseher eingeschlossen das ist
internet of things
das ist etwas was ich jetzt
interaktivität zum begriff den ich jetzt
gerne einführen würde hinter optik wir
können darüber wann entsprechen also
dritte natur läuft ihnen das ein dass
hier der mensch so ein bisschen raus
genommen wird das einfach jetzt die
dinge miteinander technologie
miteinander
foto matti sierung ist ein stichwort und
er bringt hier noch als eine metapher
des 3
denken sie daran wenn sie mechanische
dinge app technologien zweiter ordnung
aufeinander beziehen haben sie immer
reiben sie haben raum zeitliche
problematik da denke sie elektroautos
energie effizienz weiter zu fordern
denken sie an den übertragungs riemen
das war ich der beste westlichen
mechanischen übertragungswege an also
und bewegungen ineinander bewegung um
gift umgehen wandelt reaktionen es etwas
was nur noch auf nach oben oder unten
geht ist es in der
taxi oder in den kreis bewegen
umgewandelt werden beide lokomotiven hat
das dann kolben beim audio und kolben
der wenn dies recht verstehen und nach
oben oben geht stimmt ist dass der eben
am ende trat also über den dreh welle
die welle das rad anträge es ist eine
solche übertragungen und sowas gibt es
dann bei der dritten in eine technologie
die ordnung nicht mehr weil es hier eine
völlige reibungslos regungslosigkeit
gibt und zwar ein völlig anderes
fähigkeiten verschiedenen technologien
auf dem selben standard sie sind
standards die wir in zukunft bringen
das kann zum beispiel so aussehen wer
sich geräte in derselben netz einwählen
neuer lässt oder dass sie auf derselben
frequenz sind und da gibt es gar keine
leitungen es gibt vielleicht interferenz
intervall endeffekt kann es geben aber
dann 17 mit sind dieselben standards
haben das er aufm pc läuft auf mac oder
so dann gibt es eigentlich keine album
er müsse sich überlegen wer gestürmt
thomas dann auch die digitale online
welt weitet sich in die analog offline
welt hinein
august und verschmilzt mit ihren dieses
jüngste phänomen für mitunter diversen
bezeichnen und liquid eres
computing-umgebung intelligenz das
internet der dinge und webmethods fingen
die erweiterung der dinge durch das netz
ich verwende dafür lieber den ausdruck
online sie sehen hier werden neue
begriffe jetzt geprägt es ist oder wird
das nächste spaltung der wicklung im
informationszeitalter sein
wir leben immer mehr eine frage an sie
zurück können sie im krieg das online
[Musik]
content dasselbe flugzeug zu ihrer also
nicht mit dem rasenmäher vorher
automatisch für erd- lassen dass ich
einmal fallen gefährt hat kriegt befehl
familie entdecken sind weiter es gibt ja
schon kennen sie diese teekocher und
laut tv heißt die firma ich werde mich
bezahlt ich glaube ich sogar noch einmal
selbst vorstellen aber es gibt sowieso
eine neue teekocher wo man dem thema der
app dann programmiert
und der ist automatisch einstellen oder
auch der kühlschrank der dann über ein
smartphone hinter mir und solche dinge
und also wir werden immer mehr
eingezogen
in online strukturen und die spielt auch
für uns eine rolle in diesem online
strukturen also anders gesagt wenn das
online
verbindung uns abgeschaltet würden dann
würden dinge auf der strecke bleiben die
für unser leben von bedeutung sind das
kann man nicht draußen also was wäre
wenn uns die verbindung gekappt würden
was fällt dem weg von und zur lebens
auch ganz ganz viele bilder das ist
natürlich auch in guten und überfordert
ja ja immer forderungen heute ohne
aktion ja erst jemand das ist dann
wieder die ethische dimension die
reserve fehler und auch florida und auch
nicht machen das so dass wir eigentlich
immer nur vom gelingenden aus als wir
definieren digitalität oder infos
während eines brandes belieferung von
digitalisierung die gesunde höchst in
der die probleme bereits über uns das
ist immer die frage auf welcher ebene
reden reden wir auf der digitalisierung
dann spielen diese ganzen dinge glaube
ich eine rolle
ich glaube dass dieser betrieb
entwickeln lässt der auf der höheren
ordnung ist wo man eben die ganzen
lösung dieser
polemische aufgelegt hat ist immer die
frage ob nicht dann trotzdem noch
gewisse ethische probleme bleiben jetzt
aber nicht rein technischer natur sie
muss sondern die einfach unauflöslich
dann dieser neuen form reagieren wie zum
beispiel eben veränderte
kommunikationsweise die gar nicht anders
gehen die in sich so eine problematik
ich will damit nicht sagen dass die
sphäre der digitalität oder die infos
von unternehmer ist aber gemäss probleme
hat sie nicht nur die nun technische
treffen und ich meine es war punkt ihr
so ein bisschen der punkt der nicht nur
technisch war das zu viel weil sie
warten oder etwas aushalten menge
aufwand zu worden
das räumlichen distanz zeitliche distanz
ein verein nicht mehr so eine große
rolle spielen und dass die vielleicht
wichtig wären das ist ein bisschen hatte
ja vielleicht auch also auf jeden fall
ist ist es sich als mensch ist man ja
ein
stellt man sich auch komplett um
vielleicht ist der psychologische
richtung genau aber das wären so der
lernpsychologie wieder auf unabhängig
von der technologie ist da einfach von
der von digitalen das in sich schon uns
im die trägt das ist halt
allen werde das ist ständig texas über
raum und zeit als die frage ist die ob
unsere natur unsere menschen natürlich
eigentliche thema gibt
ob die eben damit ein kontrast steht
man kann natürlich geben wir den
gegensätzen das dementi natur
unglaublich flexibel ist und dass die
menschennatur super passt ist dass sie
neue realitäten durch neue revolution
sich schnell ein vermeintliches die
ganze die industrialisierung haben wir
uns so was von einfach mal hat ist in
unserer natur übergegangen so dass wir
jetzt sich überlegen könnte auch nicht
eben auch die ernte digitalen dinge
offen uns einfach und integriert wird
und nicht mehr als etwas fremdes und
einfach etwas aufgehoben ist aber wir
sind natürlich noch nicht so weit ist
das wäre aber dann evolutionärer prozess
ja sicherlich schon im weitesten sinn
die menschen tue ist so flexibel dass
sie auf alle neuen revolution so
reagieren kann das integrierte und das
ist sie seien transformiert dass sie
ihren anthropologischen konstanten oder
interessen darüber lebt und sie ein
benzin also das scheint mir in der natur
zu leben wir sind so etwas wie
hochkomplexe hochflexible lebensformen
dass wir alle technischen neuerungen
integrieren und zu neuen standards
helfen lassen
mir scheint dass auch unser
revolutionäres erfolgskonzepte sein
leben auf neues ganz kreativ und
integrativ einzugehen
trotz aller probleme die damit
einhergehen die wir ja auch nicht
aussparen
und jetzt fallen die zahlen auf den
folien den bildungsanbieter ja dieses
buch ist dieses buches genommen das buch
kann ich ihnen auch gerne zur verfügung
stellen damit sie danach zitieren können
auch in ihren hausarbeiten können sich
immer auf diese folien beziehen dessen
die sie bezahlen und wenn es zum
beispiel mal sowas gibt folgende darf
hier sein schrägstrich und der mann der
2008 40 außerdem das ist praktisch das
material was in dem sie angeben dass sie
dann daraus was machen können wie sie
wollen
unser angebot jetzt gehen wir zur info
sphäre und dessen wichtiger begriff also
sagt wir infos faires und ein
neologismus den 1970 er als 14
geprägt wurde wer ist im ausdruck
biosphäre nachgebildet mit dem wir jeden
beschränkten bereich auf unseren
planeten bezeichnen kollegen möglich ist
der begriff der infos während wickelt
sich schnell eng gefasst beinhaltet er
die gesamte informationelle umwelt die
von sämtlichen informationellen dem die
täter die mit ihren eigenschaften
interaktion prozessen und
wechselbeziehungen gebildet
es ist dies eine umwelt die einen
vergleich mit dem cyberspace erlaubt
sich jedoch insofern unterscheidet als
dieser gewissermaßen nur ein
unter beweis stellen da die infos wäre
außerdem dem offline und dem analogen
informationsraum mit umgreift ist
interessanter infos wäre wie sie vielen
als integratives die auch die zweite
natur mit berücksichtigt das was auf 9
und analogen ist es halt die gesamte
struktur der information die wir haben
jetzt ist natürlich hier die frage
er spricht hier von umwelt meinte ich
auch die erste natur liegt ich glaube es
nicht
ich glaube nicht dass er informationen
wie roth wird ein drittel oder nicht
wählen oder schalte ich glaube meint die
zweite natur und wenn man zum einen
möchte dritten also die ganz analogen
informationen wie alle bücher wurden wie
alle bibliotheken die ganze
menschheitsgeschichte ihren ihre
kulturgeschichte plus die digitalen
bereich von cyberspace wäre eben nur
dann die online die online-welt und
infos fähre ist praktisch online plus
ist es halt die sphäre der information
und der zweite trip natur hier
diese analoge informationen und
diese hinterhalt dazu und dies zusammen
die titans des heiles bild und das ist
die führung
so bestätigte
das ist oder so ist aber es wäre
und dazu gibt es halt auch die anderes
finde ich weiß nicht ob das so sinnvoll
ist aber gut information desinformation
wir müssen alles zusammen nehmen klar
wir sollten nicht nur digital
information davon erscheint das ist weit
gefasst ist die infos wäre ein begriff
der sich auch sony mit deutlichkeit
verwenden lässt wenn wir letztere
informationen auf diese fallen die sich
sagen was wirklich ist ist nicht wie je
gezeichnete vernünftig sondern ist
information l und was gibt formation l
ist ist wirklich dessen bezug auf hegel
der in seiner rechtsphilosophie einmal
diesen satz gesagt was vernünftig es ist
wirklich und was wirklich ist es
vernünftig und klug
das setzt jetzt vernünftig das rationale
mit informationellen also wir müssen
hier eigentlich jetzt noch mit unsere
liste hier eingeben
proposition oder nationen
das heißt das hängt natürlich auch
wieder semantik wieder interessante
positionen sind einfach selbst die
thesen in italien etwas enteilten was
war dann behaupten und das scheint auch
mit rasse und tee und essen also jemand
es rational der position verstehen
positionen jemand etwas sagt was war der
instanz zu machen wer nur dinge sagt die
revers waren falsch ich würde mich ja
dass rational anziehen würde ich sagen
ja gut
anderes beispiel eines gegenbeispiele
frage frage enthält keine position ist
heute schönes wetter dieses tages die
frage hat die mt keine position aber
dennis janson hat es den philosophen der
anfragen gestellt
und der name der aktion mensch also wie
gesagt aber so kann das war natürlich
der lage pro position zu verstehen
wahrscheinlich informationen kooperation
zu tun zu haben
und dann wird es ein bisschen schwierig
eben sinneseindrücke als proposition zu
erfassen
das heißt wir haben jetzt wieder da ein
bisschen ärgern und begriff jetzt
entwickelt der auch lediglich so wie
dies im fonds wäre ein bisschen wir sind
einfach dinge die sie zu fragen
aufpassen müssen wir alle kennen aspekte
einen reibungsfreien infos fähre aus
täglicher erfahrung etwa dass bern weil
jede e-mail praktisch frei fließt oder
die kleinste mengen dosierung alles
heute auf jedem portal eine sense
ankommt kann solche daten zu papier
leitfähigkeit wirkt sich mindestens
vielfach aus jetzt bringt er hier sein
da der folge waren kulturelle lebenswelt
zu folgen erstens erleben wir eine
substanzielle aushöhlung des rechts auf
nichtwissen in einer immer reibungslose
mal selbst ein problem
reibungsloser funktionieren im info
sphäre verliert die behauptung man habe
nichts gewusst
anlässlich von leicht vorhersehbare
ereignis und kaum ignorieren fakten zu
nehmen an glaubwürdigkeit
also die frage ist gibt es ein recht auf
nichtwissen ganz verwandt mit der frage
gibt es die pflicht zur wahrheit müssen
wir uns immer müssen wir uns immer die
wahrheit
das geht so ein bisschen diese richtung
das war eine große frage der
nachkriegszeit
zweitens kommt es zu einer
exponentiellen zunahme an gemeinsam
wissen dieses wieder lese kurve kann
auch wissen einsetzen von y die ist
einfach terminus aus der logik und mit
dem allgemeinen fälle bezahlt werden
alle nicht nur wissen dass petersen
proposition ist ein außerdem jeder weiß
dass alle wissen dass jeder weiß dass
ping denkt sie einen freundeskreis und
dem information über ein soziales medium
geteilt werden und könnte dass das
metall ist weiß nicht nur was der fall
ist sind auch wer weiß was das etwas der
fall ist mit arbeit sein
ganz interessant wenn wir wissen zum
netzwerk mäßig partei
dank dieser unsicherheit wenn ich mich
auch einmal seminar mit erkenntnis wie
befasse ich mich mal wieder was ist denn
wissen das geht mir also vielleicht
nicht auch nicht zusammen vor dem weg
also ein traditionelles leben wissen
ware gerechtfertigt
also wissen wäre zum beispiel nicht wenn
ich jetzt einfach mal vermuten oder
durch münzwurf wie eine position aus
wähle ich greife blind in einem topf von
positionen in allem besteht darin ein
sprecher der easa an einem anderen
kugeln entsteht nicht anders sagen heute
ist es schönes wetter ist schlecht das
wirklich keinen 3 und erhalte eine wahre
aussage reicht das nicht ungefähr
wissens zu reden zeit ich muss immer die
gründe dafür geben wie ich zu der
aussage genau
und hier ist wissen sehr schwach
gefasste enke sehr weit gefasst hier
geht es nicht um erkennen ist hier geht
es ihr noch um fakten und positionen das
formulation in der hocke als das heute
schönes wetter ist dass die jetzt mit
dem zusammenhält ist das leer jetzt das
erreicht hat und die das einfach solche
zeitungsüberschriften
weniger als um die gar nicht mehr der
pst misch und der fragfinn das ist ein
weiteres problem mit ms theologie wie
können wir überhaupt das verifizieren
hier wird einfach davon ausgegangen dass
die information klar ist dass gleich
auch noch ein oder punkt gibt es falsch
informationen sorgen weil sie wir müssen
hier noch einen traum vom pedal nehmen
war eine falsch
danach sollen
der scw unfallstellen auch noch eine
position für position ein bisschen aus
die aber falsch sind
aber die sehr geschickt sich als
informationen tarnen und die eben
gefühle dieser häufig untergehen oder
besonders interessant erscheinen
aufgrund ihrer bloßen form wohl des
ortes wo sie gepostet wie sie medial
eröffnet werden drittens verstärkt den
effekt der beiden eben angeführten
phänomene außerdem schnell bei meta
informationen darüber wie viel
information nicht vorgelegen hat und er
hätte vorlegen sollen immer größeren
mengen körper ist die folge dessen
erleben die eine stetige zunahme an der
verantwortlichkeit der akteure
je mehr ein stück informationen einen
bequemen klick weit entfernt ist desto
weniger wird uns nachgesehen werden wenn
wir ihn nicht mag die informations und
zu uns technologien sorgen dafür dass
die menschen moralisch eine immer
größere verantwortung tragen für den
zustand in dem sich die welt befindet
wem würde oder bewegung sollte das ist
ein bisschen paradox weil die kts auch
teil eines umfassenden phänomens sind
dass die eindeutige zuschreibung der
verantwortung bestimmte handelnde person
achtjähriger und zweifelhafter macht
also wie gibt es das problem der
identität wer soll was wissen wer weiß
was und das problem der moralischen
verantwortung wer hat die pflicht sich
wie es information informieren und wie
zu handeln das ist jetzt ein bisschen
ethische aspekte wir könnten prinzip
ihren alles wissen wir leben von unseren
fans sind dann wiederum spielen
wie können wir das nur wirklich kritisch
prüfen was von informations südbades
etwas falsch und hier stehen wir vor
einer ethischen herausforderungen der
information dass eigentlich alles mit
den formationen und jetzt möchte ich am
schluss noch auf die ontologie oder
metaphysik des adventlichen der infos
will
ein blick nach florida sowie have become
a custom concept
online und im mixed cherry tree of you
may jon stewart der in web plattform auf
postmoderne opposition auf reformen
das problem ist bei citys dessen wir die
informationstechnik kommunikation zu
finden
er ist marion kessing aufhört estate
creating new realities wir werden neue
realitäten erzeugt der technischen
betriebe hier anlagen based offline und
der geht es cirka ist online ist fast
komplett
bei bis ins match theoretisch auf der
letter er ist mit history form von
digital spirit oder interview and merge
ingrid des wissens genommen hat deswegen
ein entwickeltes computing and agence in
den pfingst momente des obi sowie
backstage in tibet auf die information
age als er sagt hier schwelle zwischen
wo also kohlenstoff passieren offline
das ist gar kein bisschen zweite natur
die mit der ersten tour vermischt ist
die natur ist in kursdorf passiert
werden aber auch unsere viele
kulturellen dingen sind kohlenstoff
basierten und der digital bis dann mit
silikon sondern sie bezogen hat er muss
aufpassen falsche freundin silke heißt
nicht silikon basierten definition
zurück welches des 17
es liegt nicht das silikon ist mark auf
silikon digital unter situation und die
an diese verschiedenen welten die
verschwimmen miteinander und zwar zum
vorteil des letzten an das
das online wer jetzt sagt er hierzu sind
re und sie realisieren da sie neue
realitäten schaffen
und darum soll es auch in diesem sinn
vor allem gehen wie werden neue
realitäten geschaffen das zu behaupten
eine neue realität geht der neue
realität mit der neuen kulturellen her
glaube ich nicht dass ich glaube neue
realitäten mit dürfen hier ist der
ziemlich breiten ausbreitung einer
kultur die muss fuß gefasst haben an der
revolution erst dann entstehen und zwar
durch diese menschliche eigenschaften
adaption integration zu reden ist im
zusammenspiel mit unserer flexibilität
erfolge hatte auch von bedarf geredet
dass die industrielle revolution dürften
geschaffen
auch die dann einen gegangen wurde und
rasant erwachsenen stadt ist und
natürlich auch das ist ein guter
anhaltspunkt den mann und definitionen
von was neu einziehen könnte dass man
sagt die therapie bedürfen dass wir mit
dem leben sinne ist es auch der in sicht
was neues oder sarkasmus neues auch
neben mono logisch immer mit dürften es
jetzt um das finde ich sehr gut punkt
als er wirklich etwas wird als dann als
neue center logische greifbar wenn ein
bedürfnis danach ist da man sagen das
problem mit der ersten und zweiten tour
anfangs immer das sozusagen gehalt ist
alles so entweder total natürlich und
selbst ein computer aus der natur
entstanden also treten
und da kann man das irgendwie freak eine
neue definition von neu also neue sein
und das waren sie unser punkt der
diskussion eine wehrübung ja deswegen
abgesagt haben neben der digitalisierung
oder der digitalität genauer kommt zum
beispiel der faktor ein dass raum und
zeit verändert sind
sie spielen keine rolle mehr oder
anderen weise wurde die distanz spielen
kann
und dass das internet nichts vergisst
das war auch so ein brocken sind ähnlich
also wie können wir zum beispiel
verzeihen wenn das internet nichts
vergisst oder dem leben das internet
ständig dinge vorhalten kann oder wenn
wir zum beispiel auch digitale
verbrechen begehen können identitätsklau
ich glaube dass hier durch diese
anthologie der dateien das eben dateien
unendlich häufig griffen das sind und
durch die speicherfähigkeit wenn auch
unser gedächtnis und sind das vergessen
als revolutioniert wird man das
despotische neue probleme mit sich
und dann ist jetzt im morgentau
aufgebracht wurde also das eben
bedürfnis entstehen dass er ein neues
bedürfnis tim kramer digitalität oder
infos wird immer erreichbar sagt über
einen tag konsumieren zu können immer
informations zu kommentieren zu müssen
die frage ist natürlich dies nicht immer
schon ein grundbedürfnis gewesen ist
wird der professor
[Musik]
genau das passiert was ich gerade sein
also auch unter unserer gesetze
entwickeln also dass die dritte natur
die infos für irgendwie
uns aufgenommen wird und unsere
us-senatoren vielleicht sondern zum
ersten antrag müssen in unserer
theologischen ausstattung sich da auch
dran gewöhnt
das ist ein wechselspiel gibt zwischen
kultur und der zweitvertretung ersten
punkt den man auch berücksichtigen
müssen wir sind bisher davon ausgehen
dass die ersten touren biologische natur
und ich glaube es eben immer ein
wechselspiel auch der zweite natur und
ist eine ganz industrialisierung hat uns
natürlich auf der basis der ersten natur
total verändert wir haben allergien
bekommen nur zu einem negativen sinne
die wir früher nicht hatten aber nicht
glauben sieben sind denken verändert hat
die leise wie wir denken durch die zahl
und die infos ferienort wir wirtschaft
in bäume zu portieren und ballett mobile
wird in zehn friseure das anders die
formation wie das problem versuchen
der dialog ist schiff jedenfalls für
rihannas von grateful dead space
information to be used with b das ist
sehr spannend als er sagte uns los
ferien wird keine virtuelle der
virtualität muss eine rolle spielen auch
den zimmern nicht eingegangen aber
virtuell um digitales nicht dasselbe
wird mich eine virtuelle umgebung seien
sie durch eine materielle welt mit
dahinter gestützt wird das wird die welt
selbst sein
die information ihre gedeutet wird
und sagte den ferien wird nicht nur mehr
als raum der information wahrgenommen
werden das sind sie wird das sein
schlechthin sein entscheid der migros
ist natürlich diese differenz auf wen
wir so haidinger also erst hatte ich
glaube dass versteckte zukunft heiliger
war ein heiliger vergeben das seien aus
dem konzept bringen das ist die
ontologische interpretationen
information wird irgendwann nicht mehr
nur auf proposition semantisch oder als
erkenntnisse des technologisch relevant
sein sondern als pathologie als sein
selbst um ich gebe ihm letztes beispiel
und zwar denken sie mal dass ein
bisschen weiter wenn sie immer mehr aufs
internet angewiesen sind um
informationen zu bekommen wenn sie denn
einer sache suchen gewinnt hat und es
nicht werde ich irgendwann glauben das
nicht und das ist das ist natürlich ein
fehlschluss in gefahr aber das ist ein
fehlschluss natürlich vom system ischen
einschränken aufs nicht existieren aber
wenn die infos fähre unterwegs und wenn
wir von dir weiter abgehängt werden dann
könnte das der letzte schritt sein dass
es nur das gibt was im netz oder in der
info sphäre sich auch finden lässt als
wäre da nicht ich denke als existiere
ich soll mich finden etwas alles
riskieren ist
ich finde etwas also existieren es ist
etwas in termin von zellen enthalten
dann existiert und was nicht in den
fluss fähre dann ist was ich nicht
finden kann
das existiert nicht installiert schluss
dass dem möglichen verstoß aber es wäre
eine mögliche folge befragen und
vitalität betrachten dieses prozesses
beschreibt im interview was sie hier
leisten konnten ja weil der rivale gute
wetter und die vielen nationalitäten die
bühne fällt nur beschränkt waren
sollten sich verstärkt haben
ja sie müssen besteht darauf dass wenn
sie interessieren
ich glaube dass die infos wäre sich auf
jeden fall
ich glaube dass die zinsen der welt
wirklichkeit führen wird also das eben
hat seine grenzen auch diana geografisch
bedient sind des teams fair immer
weniger gespendet worden aus wie das
wort dieses potenzial nicht so schnell
verändert ja ich denke schon ich denke
dass meine these aber dass mir vermutet
wurde ist dass die infos werden immer
mehr unseren menschen da ist er also pro
position als infos fehlt nämlich der
innerhalb unseres denkens schlechthin
ist das war auch der punkt von der bezug
auf regel werden die massen und was
möglich ist informationen was
informationen ist es wirklich ein hebel
hatte gesagt es vernünftig glaube dass
durch die infos fähre sich die struktur
unseres denkens immer mehr verbreiten
unser denkt ist eben auf ausgelegt auf
notwendigkeit und auf die vermeidung von
kontingents und zum beispiel regionalen
grenzziehung der solche dinge
erscheint der vernunft immer nur als
kontigent und der letzte hinsicht wären
dann den verlust mit dem dann wie zum
beispiel die menschen solche und sofort
geben das letzte ziel des entwicklung
ich glaube das eben ist differenzen
immer schwieriger haben werden
aufgehalten zu werden
in der infos finden von ganzen hätte was
in der entwicklung hin zu dieser
entscheidung
genau das ist den denken enthalten
glaube ich schon als der vernunft mit
dass man von der einheit entspricht was
hat ein problematisches verhalten hat
ist auch wichtig differenzierung
kulturelle situation ist es wichtig das
heißt natürlich nicht dass man es da
durchaus geben muss aber diese
grundgedanke dass es ihm so eine einheit
gibt ist die menschen leben gelebt aber
die infos fähre ist erst die möglichkeit
dass dann global osten was davor nicht
möglich durch die fehlende vernetzung
durch die raum zeitliche grenze später
durch die medien im sinne der gutenberg
galaxis also wichtiger von ich glaube
dass fünf mit dem die so große sammler
bezeichnet durch die infos wäre immer
stärker propagiert werden und irgendwann
infos fähre riesengroßes großer größen
die metallstruktur 40 die proposition
zwar noch eine meldung der quasi selber
in dieser
italien gehört
werden größer einstellt wenn es direkt
zum aufgehoben wird oder was ihr voraus
und genau das getan haben sagte dass ein
größerer einschnitt als wenn jemand
der besteht nun mal aus dem ruder pomp
letzter punkt weil erster tier jetzt das
hier eigentlich kein material mehr
dahinter - und jetzt muss man weniger
fragen stecker rausziehen was dann ja
nicht den stecker rausziehen und das
internetkabel mehr durchschneidet das
große kabel müssen alle datenleitung da
zur führung stellen was ist dann
existiert dann alles nicht mehr oder so
was würden sie sich fühlen als werber
eingefahren darunter umgestaltung
herrmann
also zumindest so wenn der strom
abgedreht wird oder warmwasser weg ist
sie kennen es ja schon wenn jetzt das
internet nicht funktionieren wenn jemals
der störung ist dann bricht eine kleine
welt und natürlich nur temporär und so
aber das so wichtige frage die frage
nach der ökologischen dem fundament nach
ihrer basis der infos während kurz
gesagt an schlusslicht ist auch damit
damit beenden
das ganze natürlich die fahrgäste kann
den fonds wäre oder die digitale die
digitalität wirklich eigenständig
existieren oder center logisch abhängig
von einer fungieren die struktur des
kann es können irgendwelche
kundenbedürfnis sagen die die internet
usw oder eine materielle struktur oder
hat sie wirklich eine eigenständige
realität und hier bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob das so eigenen existierende
floridis von mir denkt weil sie mir doch
technisch und physikalisch von einigen
faktoren abzuhängen scheint die zukunft
kann er noch weiteres liefern
aber da müssen wir glaube ich ein
bisschen kritisch das soll zwar heute
gewesen sein ich bedanke mich für die
rege diskussion wir haben ja auch einige
zuschauer und dann einige likes und
viele kommentare und wir sehen uns am
nächsten